now to our coronavirus coverage let's  take a look at our latest numbers here  nevada is reporting a 16.3 percent  positivity rate while clark county is  slightly higher out there on your screen  you can see 16.9 percent the county is  also reporting 240 cases per every one  hundred thousand now that number needs  to be below 100 in order for some  restrictions like mask wearing to be  eased and to be  again transition into lesser  restrictions and so if you want more  context on all of these numbers you see  that uh code on your screen there point  your cell phone add the qr code on your  screen and a link will pop up click that  and it'll take you to 8newsnow.com where  we explain all of the numbers